je m'appelle romane protat cvci je suis
en détention à mites
cette vidéo a été publié ce soir par le
régime le journaliste affirme être bien
traité quoique on ignore si c'est vrai
il dit coopérer avec la police et même
avoir confessé son rôle dans le
soulèvement populaire au bélarus
qu'est-ce qu'il attend exactement on ne
le sait pas mais la peine de mort est
une possibilité
sa mère en entrevue a éclaté en sanglots
et demande à l'europe de se tenir debout
pour obtenir sa libération
cette affaire troublante s'est invitée à
la réunion extraordinaire de bruxelles
en soirée prochain au stade date doit
comprendre qu'il y aura des conséquences
sévères a promis la présidente de la
commission européenne un détournement
d'avions commandés par le président sous
prétexte d'une alerte à la bombe pour
piéger un journaliste en exil
c'est du jamais vu dans l'histoire de
l'aviation européenne qui s'est passé
hier est un scandale international
nous travaillons sur des sanctions les
plusieurs gouvernements refusent
d'attendre et passe aux actes
la lituanie la lettonie l'ukraine et le
royaume uni ont annoncé qu'ils ne
voleront plus dorénavant dans l'espace
aérien du bélarus parce que c'est trop
dangereux pour qui que ce soit
l'arrestation d'un journaliste en exil
est inacceptable a déclaré la
chancelière allemande qui demande sa
libération et celle de sa copine une
russe dont le sort ne semble pas
préoccuper le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères
outre une demande d'être consulaire la
russie s'est abstenue de condamner le
président lukashenko quoique de plus en
plus isolé est contestée il peut encore
compter sur l'appui du cra mi mai pour
les collègues du journaliste en
détention le scandale
allez la perle ryanair doit ouvrir les
yeux de l'europe qu'elle réalise une
fois pour toutes que nous avons un
régime imprévisible et dangereux ici
tamar alter escaut radio-canada moscou